what then shall we do some reforms are
not difficult to envisage we must purge
our vocabulary we must clean up our
language to say what we mean what is the
true University via its libraries
it is a custodian and engagement with
the living past it strives to advance
knowledge and clarify critically the
processes of sort a true University
serves neither political purpose nor
social programs necessarily partisan and
transitory above all it rebukes
censorship and correctness of any kind
what we have done through political
correctness the lies we are teaching or
having to accept the questions we are
not allowed to are not even to ask no
question of arms free political
correctness makes impossible great
fields of comparative study a university
should house and it should honor
anarchic provocation and the passion of
uselessness what is the most wonderful
passion in the world uselessness if
someone comes to me and says I'm going
to give my life to the study of Tang
Dynasty bronzes I say you're a very
lucky person you're going to be a very
happy and hungry person but you lead a
blessed life the notion that the useless
is the highest form of human activity
first and foremost we must insist
on recapturing some of the ground the
humanities have yielded to the sciences
is a 21st century educated man a woman
literate when in total ignorance of
elementary mathematics of the conceived
of the concept of numeracy which
organize and determine the world around
us when she or he cannot grasp such
notion as a mean average an irrational
notions instrumental to our social
economic existence indispensable to
current debates on genetic modification
euthanasia and law the frequent
assignment to the least gifted to the
most disillusion of the teaching of
mathematics in our schools is a suicidal
scandal how does it go in the university
of newton and Crick if you get a first
in mathematics you can go on to research
if you get a good second you will enter
hedge funds and banking which are very
sophisticated in their mathematics if
you are assert the worst you will go
teach mathematics you realize the
self-fulfilling lunacy of such a system
overnight Stalin decided that school
teachers of mathematics would be paid as
much as university professors and
honored honored society and he brought
on the great revolution in Soviet and
then in Russian mathematical literacy it
can be done it can be done it's not
impossible it is never too late the core
curriculum should I persuade it contain
and now I hope you will bear with me
this is my one very practical reform
at the center of our curriculum should
be architecture why it draws on
mathematics very richly of course
geology what are called in English the
material sciences deal iron would come
it rose on Edward environmental politics
at every level it embodies P and
Futurity in architecture the notorious
gap between the two cultures is only
abolished haki Metis joins Michelangelo
together they teach us and the technical
phrase is so beautiful
how to read a building how to read a
building that is the phrase they teach
you there is no aspect of law sociology
environmental economics but also urban
politics which architecture does not
involve in our daily lives how to read
how to read a building how to read which
is the center of my remarks this morning
we are learning to read together no
secondary text please no criticism no
comments on comments on comments
complete loss of Cruz you learn to read
together and what you do at their end
and this is the end of my two long
remarks this morning the closing or
rather opening motion is that of
memorization we learn by heart Parker
not my brain we learn by heart the poem
or piece of relevant prose to memorize
is to sank for what the text has given
us it's the only effective way of saying
merci Thank You Duncan
for the inexhaustible liberality of
meaning for the miracle of sense what we
know by heart cannot be taken from us
never forget that